[Music]
hello everyone this is women's
Grandmaster Sabrina for sure I'm here at
the San Luis chess club and you are
watching the strategy session so for
tonight
I've prepared a couple of interesting
positions I think and we're going to
look a little bit of at prophylaxis and
then bed piece so of course you know
strategy in chess there are a lot of
very important topics that you can
consider working on but for today I
figured these would be some nice topics
so first of all let's try to see for the
people here in the club what do you know
about prophylaxis how would you define
it stop the other guy from yes your
opponent from doing something that they
want and it was aron nimzowitsch who
came up with with this idea of
prophylaxis and he was I guess defining
it that you you really you want to do to
stop your opponent from some action that
they want to do and typically from the
examples that I've seen prophylaxis is
used more in defense but for today I
want to discuss attacking because you
know oftentimes we feel that we want to
bring our pieces really fast and attack
our opponents King and made it you know
we're not thinking too much head we just
want to to kill our opponent but I think
in attack it might be even more
important so you kind of stop them from
defending and then you continue bringing
your pieces into the attack so this
first example that I have on the board
is from a game played by Judit Polgar
against Mirren in in one of the
Olympians and she reached this position
let's try to evaluate this position and
figure out
you know who is better water rights
plans flex ideas and things like that
anyone would like to share whitey has an
exchange down
first of all right mating attack okay
that sounds great right but why do you
why do you think I discussed a
prophylactic first so so basically white
hands open up the H file certainly has
sacrificed the exchange in that
therefore for a 1985 and and now has the
H file open and the week squares in
blacks position are well mostly h7 right
the H file the entire H file and blacks
last move here it was Queen e8 it's very
important to think about our opponents
last move it and what they might want to
do obviously when we see the H file and
the reason we sacrifice with white they
exchange is probably to play Bishop d3
right rook h1 if necessary and then
we'll mate in age seven or ninety five
of course is another idea but thinking
ahead on what our opponent might want to
do here can help us make the right move
the move that will give black the least
amount of chance of defending if for
example we would play in this position
Bishop d3 what do you think blacks
answer will be it's kind of f5 right
offering the Queen trade and then what
to do here with white I mean will try to
avoid the the Queen trade when we attack
especially also because we don't have
the same amount of material we will
retreat and then let's say they play
queen g6 bringing the piece to defend
so now h7 is not going to be such a big
issue for black of course we can maybe
capture in d6 pawn takes and then
maybe 95 would still give white a pretty
good position but how about our attack
white is much less likely to win this
position because of the checkmate
certainly so going back to the starting
position having had a little bit of help
what do you think
why did here in order to prevent f5 and
be able to continue their attack without
being very worried that black will be
able to stop the attack here comes the
idea of prophylaxis basically blacks
threat here the defending threat with f5
is the fact that they open the Queen so
you cannot take for example on passant
right because the Queen's are going to
be traded well in fact your coin will be
attacked so in this position Judit play
this amazing move I mean I like it very
much
Queen h3 and this book stops f5 because
now you're not offering the Queen trade
and if black were to play f5 in this
position Bishop c4 check
what does black do King h8 right I mean
he 6 doesn't seem to be holding the
position too much because what do we do
after a six
I think 95 yeah ninety-five looks nice
d6 is hanging everything will be would
be last year so King h8 okay and now
ninety-five
h6 and we can take
and this position is close to winning
for white because for example if black
takes what do we plan on doing your d6
with mating threats are we scared about
this check yeah and I think black is is
running out of out of good moves so in
the game smearing played here h6 how do
we continue our attack
Bishop d3
night before
do we give up the bishop no that's our
strong piece coming into attack and this
move has always been one my favorites I
used to play this type of positions more
from King's Indian I wasn't really ever
an e4 player this is obviously this has
obviously been a Sicilian but I've
always enjoyed a bishop restricting the
night typically I love Knights but when
the position is opened bishops are much
stronger so especially if you can you
know show domination in the position
restricting the night with the bishop I
I love those kind of moves and here
black play d6 f5 it's a very nice
opening of the diagonal of course
threatening f6 as well and rook takes c3
final try of black to to do something
here and then what would you play here
with white would you take the rook or
maybe do something else
f6
Green b5
if you double-check the black doesn't
have anything yes and maybe one little
check here what do we do
King b1 or King D to wear
pretty much anywhere after queen after
going g3 the game was over but typically
people like to give a little final check
so you can you can go either way there's
what is black going to sacrifice here no
right so so the mate the mate is coming
so I think you know if we go back to the
starting position this this queen h3 is
just a really important move for white
other moves with their gear and white
again like a very strong position but if
you want to finish the game with mate
and Jude it is known to have been quite
an aggressive and a very good attacking
player and you know this I really
enjoyed this this move from her okay
between teaming and I think I forgot the
name and check Karpov
Karpov voice was black in this position
team up team on had white and Karpov
black let's have you seen this position
before yes yes but have you seen this
particular position or no no okay so
what do we think about this position who
is better if we look at King safety
which King seems I like black skin too
yes this rook is certainly a very strong
piece for for black they have the Queen
looking at blacks get at White's King no
no protection no castle Bishop before is
a nice idea as well yes of course the
best thing that you want to do is to try
to take any five right if you have the
opportunity to do so so what would be a
natural move here that you're thinking
to do here with black you are mentioning
Bishop e5 but g5 too right
which one would you like to take on a
seven why why would you make that move
so you're feeling the idea you're
certainly feeling the idea here but
Karpov didn't take the pawn in this
position because typically a poor like
this yes in your territory he's like
please they're all over shield and it
usually like protects you and also like
having the King in a seven might allow
some checks on the diagonal and I don't
know some like so you're taking hit yes
they're ideas for white here of Knight
a5 check and potential sacrifices in in
statistics so in order to avoid those
things he play King a eight but a
natural another may be natural move to
consider here or two natural moves would
be g5 and then the other one may be d5
after do just choosing the bishop away
to try to to get to to put pressure on
e5 but Bishop d2 seems to still hold for
white you know and if you play something
like Bishop g7 maybe I can you know rook
or maybe even Bishop bishops
bishop we're after Bishop ah you want to
play Bishop d6 okay and what is the
difference if I consider playing Bishop
c3 it's quite quite similar but I love
this move it's just you know making sure
that white doesn't have any checks and
now you want diva yeah D v g5 ideas with
Bishop before check of course but those
don't work so well because there's
always like 92 they can be played to
cover so in this position white played
h4 which maybe wasn't the best but 95
wouldn't have helped either because what
happens now now be sure before right
because you're left through the night
from from d2 and now if you play Bishop
d2 rook takes e5 nice everything is
hanging so h4 okay what do we do how do
we continue with black what was our idea
with King it
right so are you gonna go for Bishop
before or maybe there are other
candidate moves here look at this beauty
d5 you cannot take on pissant
at this point I wish you could but no
you cannot so where is your queen going
it needs to be either g2 or c2 he went
III instead like if he goes Queen c2
this is what black was planning to do I
believe takes Czech Bishop here
the bishops are creating an amazing
restriction and things just will go down
for white after Queen takes c6 check
King takes ace
seven now now you don't have any checks
I keep the opportunity of playing Bishop
d7 whenever it might be needed but now I
really don't see how you can stop these
these mates coming your way everything
is going to be falling queen g2 probably
would have led to something very similar
just
and okay then we also have Bishop Bishop
before depending on where you go you
cannot really go to D to the King cos
this will be hanging as well so looking
after and I think we can do the same
I do have this check but if I let white
from going to go there then they might
bring their look into play yeah so let's
see maybe maybe I've maybe I'm not
whoring if you go there maybe I just
play Bishop here why would I hurry after
all right I don't need to hurry yeah I
heard you see I'm telling you
prophylactic but I'm I'm hearing myself
say yeah maybe just finishing the
development material is quite fine your
king is still completely in a mess here
and we're just trying to open up the
position the best way we can in the game
Queen III was played g5 now the Queen
went away from the protection of the
rook so you cannot capture with the pawn
anymore and after Bishop takes g5 what
did blood have in mind
I'm sorry
no no Bishop before explained but this
is probably fine
black has such a great position
he played Bishop here check King F to
check King G to if Bishop f4 will simply
take you cannot capture back
kingi to Arab takes you five and now
and
/ so you know maybe similar things would
have happened if he had played King
takes a seven but there was no need the
King was seemed to be more protected in
a age without black needing to be
worried about any checks and see six
wasn't going to be lost with check so
everything was fine here now I have
quite quite an interesting game by Grant
Elias and this was played in 2000 and he
played the game against Sokolov and we
have an endgame queen and rook versus
Queen and Rob seems quite equal but
that's just material wise right who's
King a safer and what shall we consider
doing here with white White's King is
safer okay why is that because of the
pawn in G - so you're trying to hide
somehow around the pond you're saying
okay what are the weaknesses in blacks
King's position 7th ranked the entire
seventh rank is is bad for black usually
anytime you have the opportunity to
activate your rook on 7th rank you have
some like it depends of course in the
position but you either have some
counter play or you have some winning
ideas and in this case without any pawns
on 7th rank and with Queens on the board
still black is going to be struggling to
defend his king particularly here we're
seeing some potential action on g7 right
so if you were black here you would love
to trade Queens because you know it's
going to be a rockin game you have G and
H pawn okay even if you lose one of them
it should still be draw and in some
cases you might even be able to draw
having lost both of them and white
remaining with
Angi pons now of course it depends on
how you manage to to place your rook and
how white manages to place their rope
but typically like there are some
chances for black but you know if the
Queen's
don't get traded they're going to
struggle this like you said so not only
seventh-ranked but the fact that they
have no way to exit from this situation
and also this check in d8 of course at
some point if you can combine it with
bringing the Queen somehow on the
seventh ring and then having some kind
of mating ideas that would be great okay
so does black have any particular
threats here that white might be worried
about or some maybe there are some moves
that you want to play with white and
it's way to move so maybe black has any
threats in my opinion black would want
Queen c5 like I said trying to trade the
Queens and a check in d8 wouldn't do so
so much damage I can just come back
maybe to to g7 and then another check I
will use my queen as a shield just
really fast and then I'll have some
checks on the diagonal and stuff like
that so what do you think white played
in this position the problem is if you
play Queen d6 in this position I think I
have this check you have to be careful
if you do so
don't I have mates here where is the
maid let's find a mating two or if one
right why not have one
it's mate right
remember this the best way you can get
your King protected the key is to keep
the pawn on the second rank or seventh
if you're black the reason is there's no
like the Queen cannot go around behind
the King and give checks if you start
pushing the pond and suddenly I have
ideas you know it's coming and the same
thing happens in King and pawn and games
if your pawn is pushed too much
sometimes there's like circling around
pushing you up and then the King comes
from behind and grabs your pawn those
are some typical ideas in in King and
pawn and game so here you don't want g3
so probably you would move king h2 and
here I've succeeded to trading the
Queens and draw it should happen so in
the starting position white in order to
avoid those situations played which one
h7h to a queen to a7 I think similar
things happen here if you do that I'll
wait I can't do that
no but I still give you the check that's
the trick because when you take it I
take your rook so now okay Queen end
games should be should be a draw as well
it may be tough but it should be that's
that's the problem also yes good point
yeah 27 so of course after queen a7 Luke
III if you go King H 2 then again we'll
have that check annoying check that
yes King edge to double exclam I think I
like it because you you avoid now any
checks and black is not in the position
of moving the rook to have those threats
again to trade the Queen and what does
black do I fill the black is somewhat in
the Suk's Bank here in this position
black played Queen c5 so I said there
was this idea of Queen c6 so the idea
would be okay you cannot take the rook I
mean you can and then I take and then
you take and then I just move there you
take and maybe I can give some checks
and try to hold this it's very tough but
maybe I can try yeah white should be
winning but it's tough in in Queen and
games you know like whether you have one
or two pawns because one of the pawns
you probably will do is and then you
just need to make sure you know how to
hide with the King around the pawn and
just avoid the perpetual check for a
really long time it will seem like you
have no way to stop the perpetual check
but you have so just keep playing and be
very happy if your opponent's king is
close to to your pawn because that way
you actually have a much better way of
hiding so in order to try to draw this
black should kind of go far with the
King because they need flexibility with
their Queen anyways this was some kind
of crazy line so after Queen Queen c6
this is another move also that that
could win the game
Quincy forecheck and now what was my
idea
hmmm let's try to try to make sure black
doesn't escape
check
and in this position if you move the
king here for example what do I want to
do
yep
thank you
if you go to e8 same thing right
and if you play for example rookie 7
what do I want to do take it
yeah the King component game is winning
right take it with the rook or the Queen
like I put my variation there and just
bring our king at some point we'll push
the a pawn they will go grab it we'll go
grab these we're winning right yes you
can never push any of the points so you
actually have to let me I will just come
all the way here and even if you push
one of the pawns I'll just come back and
I'll win them and yeah the only thing I
need to be very careful about is of
ideas that you can push h4 h3 right and
when I take it just to make sure that
your team doesn't make it back on time
to f8 so you have to calculate a little
bit but this is winning for white so
there was another possibility the black
would have done but I think the Queen
and game like is definitely winning but
if you want to make sure that you're
winning you could probably go for that
row k7 idea but in the game black played
Queen c5 okay let's try to see why was
white exchange do we exchange the
Queen's no we don't exchange because we
had these mating threats right if we
trade Queens then the routine game will
be a draw right we have no chance to
meet them even if our a pawn is far and
everything and okay here
in this position like I found the gamers
checking and it seems like black resigns
so I've added some line here to
double-check everything so we have like
some clear threads right
so probably blacks only move here
baroque at five and
yep and now he has to go here right
look up
Ruka fate
Queen Queen b8 Queenie 6:25 that's yeah
No Quimby a truck a fate right
keep going keep going Quimby 8 look a
fade and now yes we've tricked them now
they cannot do that we don't want them
to trade our Queens right so now we come
back and it's over 6 we take it right
and I made the next move
so you just need to play a little bit
around Black's defense and make sure
they really don't get to trade your
Queens and that was the reason why they
resigned we cannot go to beat to
directly because there is a check
counter check so you're forced to trade
the Queens that now you're not winning
anymore that's why by giving that check
you distract the rook from the control
of the file and oopsie sorry and here so
they went there so we do this check we
give this check they cannot play look
update we've already seen then you come
back and you take a queen of fate
rook the 8th over no checks nothing and
even these pawns like sometimes these
pawns could do some kind of damage like
g4 g3 with check but my planking h2 we
saved ourselves from everything and I
think the great part about this position
was the fact that the rook was not able
to move and that's why this move was so
awesome
King h2 if the rook would have been able
to move and black would have you know
traded Queens of course this would be
another story but I didn't have that
okay so those were my examples with
prophylaxis and I want you to also
discuss a little bit bad piece so
they've come up with some other examples
don't know why it keeps
so let's look
in a game between the Trojan and
licorice and this is not a typical maybe
example that would see by Petrosian
right he was a very good positional
player and I don't particularly like his
position here with white why do you
think so he has an extra piece but why
don't they particularly like White's
position
the bishop is doing nothing the Queen
the Queen the queen is in h1 look at
that Queen the Knights are not doing so
bad because they can come to me for and
the bishop is on the diagonal any time I
just make sure it's protected I can move
the knight and offer the trade I do have
an extra piece here for a pawn okay it's
white but routine a one also doesn't do
so much but the worst piece right now we
have the Queen in each one
okay so f3 yes and I was trying to check
to check this example I was trying to
analyzing a lot to analyze it a little
bit with the engine and it seems that
nowadays you know this position is not
as bad for white there were some ways to
kind of hold and even with that Queen in
h1 that cannot exit from there for a
really long time who managed to play
this well I mean I'm sure he would not
enjoy it but I'm sure he would be able
to hold without too much problem but but
okay
I don't know but certainly in this
position the white is going to be
struggling a lot so what is our plan
with black I mean okay the queen is
struggling but still it seems like we
have a lot of points that are
restricting us if you're thinking to
make white it will not really happen so
easily so what to do what's what's our
plan
I think in this position gligar Ridge
probably expected that white is going to
play h3 at some point to get that Queen
out so he played for that idea and
eventually white did play that and okay
we'll see what happened but yeah so this
was this was the choice that the
Petrosian had night if one was the other
option here anyways the main idea is
that you want to block it that pawn by
placing a piece there and you don't
appreciation places tonight so you want
to come really fast with the 19 g3 he
did it by playing 92 e4 Queen h4 and for
some reason here he didn't play he
didn't go for 93 here position here the
computer believes this is fine for white
now what do you guys think would you
play this I think for a human this is
completely like and III would I will
resign cuz okay I don't really have
material disadvantage but I'm sorry
the queen is because the queen is
trapped so because the queen is trapped
here in h1 it's very uncomfortable to
play I'm assuming the computer believes
that given the fact that the position is
quite closed and white doesn't have
really weaknesses besides the Queen and
they're able to kind of maintain the
pressure on the D file that is the
reason why they don't think it's so bad
because for example I think white could
just double on the e-file and just wait
for you to trade the rooks and only then
consider playing h3 if white plays h3 to
fast when the rooks are still on the
board his King is going to be in trouble
but if the rooks are out the minor
pieces might not be sufficient to
actually utilize the weakness of the
king and the better placement of the
Queen so the Queen probably will make it
out alive but anyways
after f3 to take the pawn sure okay that
is true that is true what do you think
we can do here with black what would
give us the best the best I think the
best probably would would be that
yeah I'm trying too much I'm trying too
much there I just will take and then I
think I will just try to play I mean now
the position is equal material wise I
mean I have a pond down but that really
that's going to be a problem right so
let's see can we play directly now in
this position bishop here
let's not complicate things too much
okay and let's not complicate things too
much now if you play King h1 maybe I can
just take enough - yes but I want to
utilize the G file for my rook if I play
Bishop g6 I already like give up my
option for some time to play on the G
file but this way I still have if I play
King h8 I still have the pressure
although if you plinking h1 I can't take
king f7 what do you think about this
well I was thinking if I play King h8
and you go king h1 I can't take enough
to because you'll have a discovery from
your bishop so if I'm here of course you
can play King which one but then I'm
thinking maybe rook g8 bringing the
Queen let's have the computer to make
sure I don't tell you you know something
completely silly here Oh
so after this it wants to play rook f7
very tricky very tricky okay
no actually once Queen h4 and then bring
the other look so still keeping the
pressure but oh this is nice move rook F
seven
yeah what I wanted to do here what was
it Bishop d4 oh it gives equality at
least I didn't say something completely
stupid
it's good to know King h8 King h1 and
now it says a5 so you're kind of moving
on the other side or Luke g8 is fine too
but you cannot take enough
you cannot take enough - ok so since I
could look up seven just giving a decent
decent position for white very good very
good point taking an f3 ok so let's see
the game let's go back to the game so
after f3 white plate knight Knight e4
and here for some reason he didn't play
Knight G 3 but played h3 ok what do we
do with black mmm interesting idea
bishop here first though he wanted to be
ready for mate if g3 afterwards you know
mate so now in this position if white
takes what is happening
no no it's it's black to move here
Bishop's III and and now what do you do
with which Kris do you take back you
cannot take it the night
still that great
okay Queen takes back I'll have an
exchange up should be able to win
Ruki three takes he wanted to make sure
white will die with the Queen there I'd
really feel bad I mean yeah
Queen takes after I finally escaped for
some time Bishop g4 okay
h2 King G to tweenage five what is the
threat Bishop of three and stuff Knight
went to d2 going for this of course and
now okay
the game lasts just a little bit longer
just took the bishop I mean you really
you're really struggling here with white
I mean you have to stop this you have to
stop this you have to stop this so he
decided to give up some material but and
get his queen out but he didn't even
take the rock he just came back he there
takes the rock
and okay now of course after the last
move Luke takes you for the mate or well
this is coming so he resigned so this
was quite interesting but of course yeah
as we analyzed together we we found some
potential inaccuracies in the game you
know so I I like the example because
it's rare that you see a queen trapped
you know all the wait here
hold away in each one so it was it was
quite it was quite fun okay to finish
today
let's look really fast at one of my
games it's not I didn't play it against
a strong player it's just I really like
how how I was able to get his knight
completed restricted so I hope you will
enjoy it as well and that's we don't
have so much time left so this is a game
that I played recently in in tournament
in Atlanta and what do you think about
this position white is very why
that is true that is true so immediately
when you see this position I think is a
little bit you know crazy for white
because the king is in the center and
these points have been pushed a lot and
then the age file is open and it can
give you the impression that white is
not doing so well in this position
however just because I can use in the
center it doesn't necessarily mean that
it's a bad King or it's it's going to be
how to say like mate it easily by the
opponent right you have to look not only
on how many pieces you have around the
king but also on how many pieces your
opponent has around your king and how
easily they can get to it if they are
not close by and in this case all of
black's pieces that could reach the king
are somewhat restricted like the 1986
very well pointed this bishop which
typically could give some check on day
51 diagonal is completely not doing that
the Queen like the e-file is close by by
the pond and you have no way of opening
it and as long as I'm not hurrying to
castle you have no way to try to attack
my King if I castle yes l-let me there
are some ideas you can try to play me
for 25 mating ideas or maybe some
sacrifices in g4 although even those I
don't know how you will do with the 1986
but let's just imagine that would be
possible if you had a night there and
then open the H file but at this point
like black cannot do any of those things
so I've been totally happy with my King
here in the center plus you have your
King in the center too and any time you
will Castle I can consider castling as
well okay going away from the King the
communiques position which I actually
prefer I'm I mean they're about the same
let's say the pawns right so someone was
mentioning that my pawns are kind of
crazy looking but they're linked to each
other you know
I mean this one is c6 is well protected
and no one attacks it and it's a
postponed already typically you see
positions with this pawn being in c4
right and you're quite happy with white
but here you're even more happy because
it's fast and although this is something
I'm not thinking at all of doing at the
moment to play b5 in an endgame if that
Knight kind of goes away from there I
will consider but not now okay so this
is a move I would not consider why
wouldn't I consider to play b5 to
protect I'm allowing that night that has
only one square to go to c5 and I don't
want to do that I just played before
like two moves earlier to make it go to
a6
yeah if they could switch down yeah I
wish there was there was that
opportunity sometimes you know to
improve your your minor pieces like that
that would be so awesome but I'm of
course for this position for this game
I'm happy it's not possible
so what else okay in this position so if
black is trying to somehow make these
position work it's going to be like
maybe rook da definitely to get the rook
if somehow I ever have the chance to
push your knight ob8 you will be having
two dead pieces over there that cannot
move and probably that's what he would
try also I have to say I'm quite proud
of my bishops I'm pretty happy with my
bishops they're great like this one
keeps any e4 III that could open up
somehow the position and also stops any
kind of you know Queen activity in g5
right everything like keeps making safe
in case of some checks somehow and this
one is certainly creating some dangerous
ideas if ever you move your Bishop d7
will be a problem okay with that said
what do you think I played here with
white here some candidate moves yeah but
if you play Queen d5 can't they just go
route d8 you see there's a reason for
which I pointed out this bishop I wish I
would remember how to make other colors
here finally I pointed out to this
bishop this is my favorite piece of this
game ah finally green yes no bishop the
bishop needs to be opened Queen d7 oh I
didn't hear that did you say it
ah okay he went their way no and here
it's totally up to me if I want to take
this change or if I want to take your
knight right
the knight is trap so feel free to go to
be a but then I win a rook right so I
can I have this opportunity of winning
the 1986 which is completely out of play
and that was my idea and you know maybe
about like five six years ago I played
in a tournament and I had such a good
tournament and then I started losing
game after game it was a tough
tournament but I lose I started losing
game after game and the last round I
thought okay it's going to be over and I
had black and I played some Catalan with
black and I lost a game because of this
kind of idea with a bishop in b7 like a
bishop would like a knight move to g5
opening this bishop and and and there
was nothing I could do and I had exactly
the same thing the black has in 1986 in
a routine I ate and since then I told
myself I would remember that idea
forever and if I ever can do it I will
do it I mean typically after a painful
painful loss you don't want to you
want to forget about those games but I
wanted to make sure I I learned
something so I kept that idea in mind so
that wouldn't work so my opponent played
King f8 here okay and now I went Bishop
f1 so I still attacked the night and you
don't really have much to do if you take
intermediate move and plane i b8 what do
I do
Bishop back yeah
and then the rook is dead so he ended up
going back Knight to be eight here and
played Queen c8 totally happy with my
position I mean you cannot go Queen e8
you have to go back either Bishop there
or Queen there he went Queen there if he
goes Bishop Queen B 7 for example yeah
he went Queen d8 and ok here I have
multiple ways to win but I chose this
one took Bishop g2 and my opponent
resigned but you can also do rook c1
yeah you can also play rook c1 here
because of the back rank problem so you
see I mean it's very important to
evaluate the positions when you're not
sure what to do anymore and just try to
be objective with the position that you
have don't overdo it but don't don't
also like you know just immediately
judge the position because you know
they're these characteristics that you
know of and is they're going to give you
a much better judgement no like you
really need to try to stay objective and
think for yourself and for your opponent
and then if your opponent really has
some ideas they will put them into play
and you should figure that out but if
they don't then simply just make sure
you you try to stay objective and and
make the right judgments and once you
evaluated the position look
or for the way to to approach your worst
place piece or your opponent's worst
place piece and do a little bit of
calculation to but other than that yeah
okay well I hope you enjoyed to this
class and I'll see you next time Thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]